We're starting into chapter 5. Now, this is basically the same age group as chapter 4,
but we're looking more at their social emotional development at this point, whereas there was
a lot more focus on the cognitive. Well, if we're going to talk about social
emotional development, we have to talk about Eric Erickson. Erickson, as we discussed in
chapter 1, was a little different than most of the other psychologists because he had a
lifelong developmental theory, as you can see here. Now, we're just going to cover these
first ones right here in this chapter, and the other ones will get covered as we move
throughout the course. You will need to know all of these eventually. They are something,
again, that tends to show up on your national exams. But Erickson believed that personal
development in steps or stages throughout your lifetime and that social experience is
those interactions you have, those relationships you have. He believed that those had a huge impact
across a person's whole life. His theory worked on a principle that each stage paved basically
this path to the next stage of life, that each part of your life had some sort of a conflict that would
directly impact your development as a person if you didn't overcome that. Now, sometimes they
were called crises, sometimes they were called opportunities. Either way, same thing, he just
used two different terminology. And what would happen is you would either develop this quality,
and your path of psychological development was good, or you didn't develop this quality,
and then you had a problem as you moved into the next time. Now, sometimes what would happen is,
is if you were successful in one, then you tended to be more successful in the next one.
But you could also lose some of them as you move forward. So again, we'll kind of talk about this
in more detail as you go through these different stages. But his whole thought was that if you
develop these, then you would have a smoother and happier life as you went from birth basically
to older adult. Erickson first stage is trust versus mistrust. And this happens between birth
and 18 months old. Now, the important event in this particular time frame is feeding. You have
to remember that at this point in a child, they're basically completely dependent upon adult caregivers
for everything that they need. That includes food, warmth, loving, safety, nurturing. If any of these
things that are critical to our development as a person isn't given, then that child is going to
suffer. So if the caregiver fails to provide any kind of outer queer love, the child will become
feeling that he or she may not be able to trust or depend on adults in their lives. And this ability
for the child then can diminish. Now, the other thing which remembers that the only way that the
child has to communicate at this point is crying. It's very limited. So the response of the caregiver
quickly to a crying child will help the child develop trust. We have to understand that
a child who's very young, let's say up to six months, if they're crying, there's a real reason.
There's something that is upsetting them. They're not being bad, but because it's the only way for
them to express it. Unfortunately, we don't always understand why the child is crying. We may think
we know, but many times parents are really misdirected on what they believe is happening with the
child. A very classic example is a child who I will hear and I've heard this from parents.
Oh, you know, my child's so fussy. They always cry when I put him down. They just want me to hold
them all the time. I don't understand what's wrong with this child. It just constantly wants to be
held. It's so needy. Well, take the child to the doctor and what you find out eventually is that
the child has acid reflux. And so every time you put the child down in bed, the acid reflux goes
into the throat, which burns the throat. So the child cries, then the child gets a little sip
of milk because the parents think, oh, they're hungry and the child stops crying because the
milk sues the throat. And the child learns very quickly through operant conditioning that laying
down is not a good thing. It hurts. So they don't want to lay down. It's not so much that they want
you all the time as much as they don't want to lay down. And so that inability to understand what's
going on with the child can basically begin to develop mistrust, especially if parents are beginning
to feel tired and they don't understand what's going on and why is the child acting this way.
We just have to remember that crying is the only communication that many of these children have.
We just talked about speech and speech development isn't there. So it's really important for parents
and for you who are going to be caregivers, nurses and things like this to understand that there is
a reason a child is crying. There's something that is not right. It may not always be physically,
but crying needs to be addressed because it could be a way that we're going to develop mistrust.
So caregivers who are inconsistent or emotionally unavailable or even just reject the feeling that
the child is having, then that child is going to begin to develop a lack of trust in human beings
and a failure to develop trust from result in fear and believe that the world is inconsistent
and unpredictable. Now the truth is no child is going to develop a hundred percent sense of trust
or a hundred percent sense of doubt. Erickson actually stated he believed that development was
more about striking a balance between the two up aside, that when this happened the child acquired
hope then, which Erickson described as an openness to experiencing tempered by some
weariness of danger that may be present, just to kind of understand that without trust there can't
be hope. Now one of the things that's interesting about trust and this is sort of a little side note
is that there have been some studies recently that shows that the level of trust that a person
may have might have some genetic makeup to it also that they've pretty much now determined that the
level of mistrust and distrust a person has is basically learn from your family and your social
influences around you. So if you have learned to mistrust or distrust certain groups of people
then that's going to stay with you and you learn it really really early and that's kind of the scary
part. So the next one is autonomy versus shame and doubt. Here we've got 18 to probably three
although some kids might be two and moving out of this stage more likely the girls and the boys
but the big important thing as you can see is going to be toilet training. Why? Because at this
point in development children are starting to gain a little bit of independence they're starting to
want to perform some basic actions on their own make some simple decisions about what they prefer
and now by allowing kids to make these choices to gain some control parents and caregivers are
helping children to develop that sense autonomy. Autonomy is important because autonomy leads to
independence. Kids are dependent though still on the caregivers for safety and for direction
so this balance has to be there between the two. Now Erickson he kind of believed that learning to
control one's old body function led to this feeling of control and sense of independence.
If you really think about this you know the fact that my bladder controls me rather than me
controlling my bladder that leads to a sense of feeling of of lack of independence. As elderly
people get older and they might become incontinent quite often a lot of times they really feel the
shame because they feel like I've lost this ability to control a basic bodily function
so if a little kid can gain that that feels like they've lost so they've gained a lot of control
over who they are. They also like to begin to control things like food choices and which toys
they do and maybe even which clothes they want to wear. Now the children who are successful are
completing the stage feel like secure and confident while those who are not well they're left using
feeling pretty inaccurate and they tend to have a lot of self-doubt. Now Erickson believed that
achieving a balance between autonomy and shame and doubt would lead to what they call will which
is a belief that children can act with intention and with reason within limits. Now how does one's
foster this is the question. You need to provide opportunities for kids to be independent let them
make some choices as an example perhaps once a week they can choose what a family is going to have
for dinner. Now that doesn't mean that you give them a gazillion choices because the poor kid will
be overwhelmed but you can do is have two choices you can say okay honey tonight you can choose are
we having macaroni and cheese or we having beanie weenies and let the kid make the choice. What's
kind of interesting is that if you let kids begin to make choices early you can lead them into
later things that really help them they'll want to do these things so gain this independence this
feeling that they can do it rather than being told all the time what to do. Now the other thing
of course unfortunately is toilet training and that can be really frustrating to us as parents
but toilet training is really important. One we have to remember that girls bodies develop
sooner than boys so girls quite often will get toilet training first not because they're smarter
but simply because the nerves within the body has grown to allow girls to understand that their
bladders are full. For boys this nerve growth can take a lot longer in fact for many boys they may
not get those nerves or that feeling that they need to go to the bathroom overnight until you
know they're they're 10 so we do have boys who are still wearing pull-ups at 10 and 12.
It is just the way of the biological body developing itself the boys go to a very deep sleep
they're so asleep they just things just roll out you might want to say. The other thing is is that
there is a psychological aspect to going to the bathroom and we probably all have seen a kid if
we've had any kids who are in toilet training who run to the corner and you know they're pooping
and you say are you pooping you hear that no no no and yet you know right there they're pooping
in line to your face and so the question is why are they doing this well there can be many different
reasons but here's one of the funny ones is that you and I as an adult we have a cognitive
understanding of how the body works but if you're asking a two-year-old who basically has just
figured out they even exist who's basically just figured out that voice in their head is their voice
you're asking him to understand the digestive system no sorry they don't get it now the little
picture I have here is a boy sitting on the toilet and sometimes this actually scares kids
not because they're sitting on the toilet and they feel like they may fall in but more because
you're flushing part of them away especially the poop now the pee that kind of disappears
into the water and it just looks like water I'm swirling down but the poop that's part of me
that that's me and I'm going away and where am I going I don't want it to leave bring it back
see you can tell them it's that peanut butter and jelly sandwich yesterday but it don't look
like no peanut butter and jelly sandwich I ever ate and they're just barely creating schemas so
you know don't give them a whole lot of thought here they may develop a little fear for a while
when they're beginning to realize what happens to this stuff now there is kind of a funny trick
you can try with some of these kids and that is to feed them a meal of corn because if anybody's
ever looked at their poop after they've eaten just corn you notice that corn still sort of stays the
same as if this might be one way to show a child that what they ate is what's coming out of them now
doesn't work with all kids but it does work with a lot of kids and kids are very fascinated
by poop because it is something that came out of their body it's part of them and they want to
understand it because it looks very different and it can smell like dinner a couple of nights ago
so kind of a fun time but the big thing is is trying to be as supportive as possible when it
comes to toilet training makes a huge difference now the last phase is initiative versus guilt and
basically what we're talking about in this third stage is something that's going to take place in
these early preschool kids age or just before they kind of go to school so from three to about five
and some of the most important events here is this ability to explore and to play now in the third
stage what's happened is hopefully and the first two stages have been successful so the child feels
like there's a trustworthy environment and as they're moving on to preschool they have learned that
they can achieve a few things by themselves now the children wants to begin to assert their power
control through play and through other social interactions they want to pick who they play with
they want to pick what activities they do they they want to have some power over their choices
so kids who are over directed they may struggle later on to develop a sense of initiative to have
confidence in their own abilities and choices now they might even fear trying new things because
they might be wrong because they were told they were wrong or they don't feel that you've had
confidence or anybody's had confidence that they can do this correct but children who are
successful at the stage they feel capable they're able to lead others those who fail to acquire
these skills are quite often left with this feeling of guilt self-doubt this lack of initiative so
an ideal balance would be that a person has some initiative and some willingness to work with others
to achieve and this quality would be known as purpose would emerge there is no purpose if i
don't think i'm going to be successful so why should i bother to try and why we may be thinking
sometimes that we're really helping these kids what we really tend to be doing is killing their
purpose so maybe your child brings you this lovely little drawing that they have and when you look
down the dog has got three legs on it now they say it's your dog sparky and your dog sparky has
four legs you may say well you know sparky does have four legs well what you've kind of told the child
is that their drawing isn't good enough how do you know that leg isn't behind another leg
you know the point is that the child is drawn sparky and it wasn't supposed to be an absolute
representation of sparky after all the kid is what four um so we do things that may and in the long
run sometimes make our kids feel more guilty maybe a kid goes and puts some dishes in the dishwasher
because they're feeling you know like i can do that i can put my dish away and they haven't put
it away exactly the right way and you go by and you say well let me show you how you do this right
what have you just told them that what they did was wrong and why try because they didn't do it right
yeah you know that might mean that you have to run a dishwasher with some dishes that aren't
exactly set correctly but you know they've given initiative and they were successful
now this doesn't mean that we give a trophy to every kid who participates in a sport that is not
what we're talking about here what we are talking about for little kids here and we are talking about
preschoolers is letting them have some willingness and some success in what they try now the picture
you see i have here is the kid is trying to crack an egg but notice the kid isn't left alone the kid
has help to learn to crack the egg and how to sort the things and they do need to be able to make
some mistakes too those people who do everything for them and don't allow them to make some mistakes
also tends to tell the kid that they don't have a capacity to do this thing so there has to be some
sort of balance now there is another kind of concept that we talk about when we bring Eric's
in in and again i've talked about Maria Montessori but i'm going to bring her in here because one of
the things she really felt with Erickson was this initiation and guilt phase was extremely important
for the long-term development of children to succeed for themselves and so one of the things
that Maria Montessori felt was that nothing should be in the kid's territory that they weren't allowed
to be with or touch or play which basically in this case would be their room so why would you put
an outfit in the room hang it in their closet if they're not allowed to wear that outfit you're
basically teasing them with that outfit so here's this pretty little dress that this girl wants to wear
it's hanging in her closet every day she sees it but she's not allowed to wear that dress so even
if she takes it down because we're not talking about three rolls having a whole lot of self-control
or four-year-olds having a lot of self-control she takes it out she puts it on and you get all
upset because she's wearing this dress well the truth is it might not have should be in her room
why is it there everything in their space everything that's within their territory
should be something that they can touch something they can reach something that they can achieve with
because if we don't then we're basically making them feel guilty so you may have a child who wants
to dress themselves after all if they're in autonomy and chain stage that's one of the things they want
to do they want to make some choices but the same point you don't know if you can take those stripes
and polka dots that they like to put together so a simple thing get yourself 10 hangers with little
clips and make 10 outfits to be honest shorts and things like that aren't that expensive put a pair
of shorts put a shirt put an underwear put the socks put it all together and hang it in the closet and
then the kid can just take the hanger out now the other thing is we can't overwhelm the kids with
choices so if a kid is at that point where they want to dress themselves and do all this take two
or three outfits out hang them on the doorknobs and say in the morning you pick from these but
the truth is the kid goes into the closet picks another one to wear unless there's some real
reason why they can't wear that then let them wear it and if it's something that they really
shouldn't be wearing it shouldn't be in their closet and if you don't want them pulling everything
out of their drawers and put everything on hangers with clips and they won't be able to pull everything
out of the drawers this is only going to last for a couple of years folks it will really make your
life easier if you kind of can do these things but it also will give them this sense of purpose
i've got a purpose for doing this i've got a purpose to move forward
attachment is a critical element for the development of any human if we think back on
what ericson just said you'll notice that attachment was critical to the very first stage of trust
and mistrust if there isn't attachment then we don't develop trust in fact attachment will become
this engine later on with our social emotional and and our cognitive development we know is that
attachment provides infants with this coping system basically it sets up this sort of mental
representation of their caregiver in their mind and when they need it they can summon this to sort
of comfort them when that person may not be around or in a difficult moment they can use that person
to give them some sort of stability what attachment does do is it allows infants to separate from
the caregiver without distress because attachment allows me to still be connected to you even if
i'm not physically with you which means that i can then go explore my world some and still know
that there's someone sort of around someone there for me now why we know this is so important to
people is that research has shown that infants who have attachments early or develop attachments
actually stimulates certain areas of the brain to grow and when those areas are stimulated
attachment will then become even more important to them and later on these same individuals also
tend to be able to develop stable relationships with others now neuroscientists believe that
attachment is such a primal need that there's actually this network of neurons in the brain
that's dedicated to setting in motion um the processes to make this happen there are actual
hormones that are linked directly to attachment within the brain now as you read their attachment
though is not automatic it happens in stages and so that's what we're going to look at next is sort
of the stages of attachment as i said in the last slide we're gonna talk a little about some steps
toward attachment now i will say this though that there is many different theorists out there that
talk about attachment your book presents john bull um one of the reason that they present them is that
he sort of the most modern and theorists you might want to say out there he just died in 1990 so
he's a pretty new guy um evolutionary theory of attachment suggests that children come into the
world biologically pre-programmed to form attachment with others um this is because it helps them
survive those who seem to be attached to somebody were more likely to receive comfort and protection
and they absolutely have shown that they're more likely to survive in adulthood this is not just
seen in humans but this is also seen in the great apes it's seen in most of the mammals
so when we have an attachment it helps our survival so infants produce this sort of innate social
release behavior such as crying and smiling that sort of stimulates this innate caregiver response
from us as adults now by the way the reason i'm saying caregiver is that it isn't always the
mother i don't want this thought to be in your head that it has to be the mother this can be the
father this can be the grandparent this can be an adopted person um it doesn't have to be a
biologically the mother so we use the word caregiver to be a more general type of scenario because
there are different people who this could occur to now they determined the attachment we found out
bowls found out is that it's not food but care and responsiveness seems to be the primary one
and the reason we mentioned this is that for a long time the thought was is those who feed
or who they become attached to well not really it's more about caring so even if um we had somebody
else who was feeding them all the time but they weren't the primary caregiver such as let's say
a wet nurse was at one point but somebody else was the caregiver they would attach to that person
now what he suggests is a child would initially form only one primary attachment and that attachment
figure acted as a secure base for exploring the word the world sorry the attachment to a relationship
acts as sort of like this prototype for all my future social relationships so having something
disrupt this can have some very severe consequences he also believed that or at least he suggested
that there's this critical time period for the development of attachment between zero and five
years that if an attachment hasn't developed during this period time period a child will suffer
basically something that's unreversible as far as their development um it would perhaps even
reduce their intelligence and increase their aggression and we have seen that children who
don't have attachment quite often don't get attention and that lack of attention does develop
as we've mentioned before certain brain abnormalities so attention is something that children want
touches and then children have to have how do they get that attention well they develop an
attachment now that person is sort of bought into taking care of this particular small human
who can't take care of themselves so when you look down through these and you look in your
your the material you can see though that real attachment to one person doesn't really
happen until about seven months old and that point we get something called separation anxiety
yes we get the crying kids and you're like wait a minute this little baby i could pass around to
anybody and it didn't cry at all and now all of a sudden if i leave for two seconds the kid falls
apart well that's because they finally have a true attachment to something and you have to remember
that a little kid we are talking seven to eighteen months old they wear their emotions on their
sleeve well if they have a sleeve basically they can't control their emotion their emotional
centers just there so what they know is that you're leaving and i don't want you to leave so stay
here and i'm not happy because you're leaving and i don't want you to leave and so the separation
anxiety happens the nice thing is is that you know about after 18 months they begin to understand
that there's a schedule and that the caregiver will be back why do they get this because they have
more brains remember they don't even know who they are between seven to 18 months i don't even know
what that voice if they even have a voice at that point in their head don't give these poor little
guys a lot of abilities they basically are just pure instinct so they begin to understand this
the caregiver schedule a decline in separation protests begin to happen although you can see an
incline again when they get to be about two or three in some cases you know depending on if it's
bear boy or girl because what they've begun to realize is that you might be gone for longer periods
of time or they may have now have their ability to have some attention and so before they didn't
even notice you were gone you dropped them off a daycare they were like oh toy and walk toward the
toy didn't even notice you going up the door but now they kind of know when you get to be too
that while i love that toy the truth is you're about to leave and i don't like that i want you
to stay because i enjoy you but if you also notice that by the time you get to the car the kid has
stopped crying and they're happily playing you have to remember again that their emotions are on their
sleeve and we'll cover emotions a little bit later in this lecture today
so following up with attachment boil believes that they are four distinct characteristics of
attachment the first one is proximity maintenance basically there's this desire to be near the people
we're attached to and safe havens kids want to return to that attachment figure for comfort
and safety especially when they have a fear or they have a threat which means that these attachment
people act as a secure base from which a child can explore surround come back to and finally he
also said that there should be some separation anxiety basically when they leave there should be
some sort of a distress that the attachment figure isn't there so in the 1970s mary andsworth wanted
to follow up on some of this work and she came up with sort of a groundbreaking research study
she took these 12 month to 18 months old so they're really little and they would go into a room
with their primary caregiver the one they were most attached to then the caregiver would leave
what they did is they observed the behavior of the child and the caregiver would return
not too long after that and again they would observe the behavior of the child had it changed
or was there something different that it occurred so what they found was that there was definitely
patterns of behavior and with some additional research by a few other people we've kind of
come up with four types of attachment relationships now i do want to say that in most cases these names
of these types of attachment relationships are pretty standard a few of them though seem to flip
flop when i look at different books and different theorists um newer names versus older names
so while i think most of your nurses you won't have to know the exact attachment relationships
names for your psychology students make sure you stick with the one that your instructor uses
as far as that but almost all of them have the first one which is the secure attachment
basically what we have here is children who can depend on their caregiver
and they do show distress when they're separated and they show joy when they're united
although the child may be upset what we do find is that they feel assured that the caregiver will
return so when frightened the securely attached child are comfortable or are confident in seeking
reassurance from their caregiver the next one are the avoidance attachment now avoidance children
attachment tends to avoid the parent or the caregiver they tend to show no preference between a caregiver
and a complete stranger now remember that these are children who should have by now at least shown
some preference and attachment now when we see this type of behavior this may be a signal that
there's some sort of abuse or neglect from the caregiver however it could also be that there
are children who haven't yet attached because of the age 12 to 18 months we also know that
there are attachment disorders that are out there so it is one that we're very leery of when we see
we like to investigate a little bit more now what happens is is that if these children don't learn
to attach or rely on a caregiver they may avoid basically making any kind of relationships in the
future or have a very difficult time making those relationships in the future the next one that
we're going to take a look at is what's called disorganized attachment these children display a
confused mix of behaviors they seem disoriented they seem dazed maybe even confused sometimes they
avoid or resist the parent sort of this lack clear clear attachment pattern is likely to be more because
of the caregiver behavior there may be an inconsistency in how a caregiver behaves in such cases patients
and parents may serve as both a source of comfort and fear leading to sort of this disorganized behavior
because the child doesn't quite know how to react to the parent and the last one is ambivalent
I believe your book says resistant first of all these children become very distressed when the
parent leaves they might even reject the parent by refusing any comfort or open display of direct
and they might even have some direct aggression toward these parents when they come back as a result
this could be poor parenting availability these children can't depend on their primary caregiver
to be there when they need them the nice thing is that this doesn't happen very often it's estimated
only about 7 to 15 percent of you as children may fall into this this particular group generally
the information on this slide is not a surprise to anybody that the father-infant relationship is
different than the mother-infant relationship primarily because in most societies the father
is the playmate the father plays more rough and tumble than the mother does the mother tends to be
much more about reading and talking with the kids so when the kid falls down and gets a booboo
when he's playing with dad he'll run to mom because mom is the comfort giver but when mom may be
sort of talking and they want to be rough and tumble and they want to run out and be loud
they're going to go find dad it's just simply a difference in approaches and not one is but in
the other the children need both but in society at least as of today this is the difference in
approach now this may also be a somewhat biological thing in that for the way that women communicate
and the way that men communicate there is a difference in that and that difference may be
flying down to how we interact with our kids at least that's what research says
what we go into next is a very complex subject emotions and if you just even think about your
own emotions it's very complex so we're not going to get too deep into these i want you to know
that some of the basics because you are going to be dealing with children you're going to be
dealing with adults and you deal with emotions every day for the psychology majors you're going
to go much deeper into this as you go through your major classes they are though we do know
at least we sort of agreed upon that there are two basic groups of emotions there are basic emotions
and complex emotions now even though many psychologists have accepted the theory of basic emotions
there's really no consensus about the price number of emotions so one very famous um psychologist
Robert Plunkett said that there were eight emotions anger fear sadness disgust surprise
anticipation trust and joy and he arranged them on a color wheel very very popular now another
one that's pretty popular is paul eckleman originally he proposed that there were seven basic emotions
and that's what you're seeing here in this picture is seven basic emotions now what's interesting is
that he comes back and he changes it to six he basically what he does is he eliminates this one
right here contempt why does he eliminate that because what he says is that basically the emotions
basic emotions i'm going to make this in red and so there you go that basic emotions are
something that are universal and that universal tea about them it doesn't matter whether you're
here in the United States or you're a baby over in New Zealand or you're Russian that they
are shared and he really felt that contempt at least the face and the expression of them was not
shared however in recent studies they found that disgust and anger also shared some similarities
and so recently we have sort of eliminated disgust and anger
which is bringing us down to basically four so right now what we're kind of at
is that happiness, sadness, fear, and surprise originally from paul but even those have been
worked a little bit so the difference between anger and disgust and the difference between
fear and surprise they're thought to have developed later in social functions and they're not really
for survival purposes and we really think emotions were for survival purposes as such more modern
psychologists have proposed that we humans have four basic emotions and that's fear, anger,
joy, and sadness so if we take a look at this what we have left is basically from paul is sadness
and we have fear and we have brought anger back surprisingly enough
and you'll know that the last one joy I guess that's a kind of like happiness so hopefully this
sort of explains to you right now that there is a lot of disagreement in psychology about
what basic emotions are what basic emotions aren't they're kind of an agreement that we
have them they're an agreement that they exist they're an agreement that we're born with them
the disagreement is how many there are and how to call them what name do we use for them
one thing we do know is that basic emotions develop over time and you know I had a choice of showing
you the sad babies or the socially smiling babies and I went with the socially smiling babies of course
far more fun to look at we generally see these as you can see these babies doing this even when
they're very very small infants they're cooing they express pleasure to see each other and then
from four to six months a new emotion emerges and that is basically anger yep those angry little
faces begin to pop out quite often this is more about frustration they don't understand their
goals they don't understand words remember they have basic little brains something isn't right
and they're trying to figure it out
so around six months old strangey where it is comes in and yes it doesn't matter who you are
even the president of the United States you don't recognize you you are a stranger and I am upset
the other thing that tends to happen about at six months is basically disgust and this lovely
little face of this guy is a face it wouldn't matter if this was a six-month-old or a 17-month-old
or a 27-year-old or a 37-year-old we know that face that is the face of disgust so these basic
emotions tend to be biological they send to be with us and what's kind of interesting is is that
we actually see them be there almost from the beginning as we begin to wire up and as we
begin to have it in fact there are some psychologists who even argue that some of these
emotions may even be there when we are born but we haven't wired our brain yet enough to make our
face move because we have to learn how to move our face we have to learn how to move our eyebrows
so we might even have discussed early on but we can't see it because the baby has no way to
communicate it since they can't talk and they may not even be able to use those facial muscles yet
so basic emotions are so called that because they are associated with this universal
recognizable facial expressions in fact complex emotions vary a lot in what they are like
in different people situations and even in cultures although grief is often taken to be a blend of
like surprise and denial and sadness and anger grief can be entirely different from person to
person and from culture to culture we know that when we talk about the grieving process we have
some people who are going to experience loss by showing anger others who are going to be
furious others who will cry others who will perhaps hit a different mental state we don't show
anything at all so different situations in different cultures give rise to these different
facial expressions that's why it's not universally recognized and why we tend to say these are more
complex in emotions what you see in front of you is basically what they call the color wheel of
emotions and here what you're seeing is how different emotions have
combinations of things so if you want to look at something like oh oh over here we can see that it
has a combination of different things that have combined to give you the feeling of awe but to be
experienced children first must be able to understand what the self is and behave in a relationship
which they've they've met standards of expectations so if i don't have any relationship if i don't
know who i am i'm probably not gonna be able to experience complex emotions so the self-understanding
you know we've already know that that comes somewhere around 18 to 24 months and the complex emotions
are going to emerge shortly after that so you're going to see they'll say 18 to 24 months up to 30
months because now we understand who we are and once we understand who we are we now can
experience complex emotions you know pajé viewed play as this integral part of the development of
intelligence and children um his theory of play argued that a child matures in their environment
and play should encourage further cognitive and language development play is just so critical
to the development of kids that even the world health organization says that a child who's not
allowed to play is a child who's being tortured now we talked earlier about play and that was
sort of a basic rundown of play but this one's a little bit more detailed so let me kind of run
through these stages if we really want to talk about play so unoccupied play at the stage a baby
is just making a lot of movements with their arms and legs and feet you know they're learning and
discovering how their body moves and that amuses them they can even smile at themselves and giggle
at themselves by certain movements that they do after all it's all new to them salatary play is
a stage when the child plays alone they're not interested in playing with anyone quite yet so
they play with the rattle by themselves they play with a bottle by themselves um this can last all
the way up to two years of age remember we still don't cognitively understand we even exist
so the thought of cooperating with another person to play that's just beyond sort of
our mental capacity when we're talking about a kid who's under two but a kid is still playing
they're playing with blocks and then around two years of age they'll go into this thing called
spectator or onlooker behavior during the stage the children like to watch other kids play but
they don't play with them they're big observers of play and they love going to the park and you
want them to go out and do something and they would much rather just sit with you and watch
other kids play this is fine what they're doing is they're learning a lot about play behavior
they're learning a lot about social interactions they will get there and then we already talked
about that when they hit two a little over two years of age after they've kind of done their
spectator observation the child will begin to play alongside others but they don't quite play
with them at this stage it tends to be referred to as parallel play so you see those twins they're
kind of playing parallel right there associative play starts happening around 304 now remember at
about three we're still not understanding other people have different thoughts this can be actually
very difficult for kids to play together because each one thinks the other one's thinking like
they're thinking so we really begin to see more associative play probably happening with girls a
little earlier because of brain development the boys a little bit later so when the child starts
to interact with others during play but there's not a large amount of of interaction at the stage the
child might be doing some activity related to the kids around them but may not actually interact
with the child so let me give you an example a kid may be playing on the same piece of play
around equipment but they're totally doing different things like ones climbing in one swinging and
when you talk to them later on they'll talk about how they played all day with Jimmy even though you
would look at it and say well you aren't really playing together but they see themselves as playing
together they've sort of mutually selected to play in that place together then somewhere around four
years of age and and the concept or the hypothesis is that children have to understand that other
people have different thoughts and that their thoughts may not be the same as as the thought
they're having in order to get to cooperative play because here children play together with others
and they have some sort of interest or activity that the others can involve and play in they're
participating in this cooperative play and so rules and games have to be had which means I need
to understand that somebody else has a different thought than me so these are really sort of the
the better breakdown of play then what your book has it's a little bit more narrowly defined
I like this one better. Play is such an important thing that anytime we restrict any type of play
it generally doesn't bode well for the kids so what about make believe play what about these
make believe people I make up it's wonderful kids should actually have some make believe in them
imaginary play promotes imagination social ability adjustment we also know that you know pretending
to do something to to survive something or do something can also help you sort of live through
traumatic things or things that might come or even frightening topics growing up here in Florida I
can distinctly remember being little and playing hurricane so make believe is kind of an important
thing now one thing I do want to point out that there is something they wrote here and I want to
make sure that we understand the difference it says 16 to 18 months olds understand the difference
between pretend versus reality and you might right now be saying but wait a minute I thought Peje said
that they had this appearance of reality and that was scary so let's explain the difference
of what we're talking about here what we're talking about is this little girl right here
if she looks on the television and she sees something she's going to think that's real because
she can see it it's thus real however in this picture she's playing by herself so she's controlling
the imagery and she knows that her little doll right here is not real she knows it's not alive
so that's the difference between seeing something that somebody else is creative versus something you
do for yourself one of the questions I always ask my classes has anybody here ever done a coloring
book that we're talking about a kid's coloring book not the new modern coloring books but a kid's
coloring book and how successful were you at coloring in that page most of you were not very
successful most of you got halfway done and gave up well if you're a little kid who has less control
of a crayon than you and if you've ever tried to use a crayon you know they are not as easy to use
as you think kids get really frustrated with coloring books they just scratch through it
it takes forever to color in a picture and then if I get outside the lines or something wrong
we actually would say for most psychologists would say don't give a kid a coloring book
better give them just some blank paper and a couple of pencils or pens and let them go at it
let them make up their own imagery let them make up their own stories that they learn to be creative
and create and look around them and decide what they want to put inside their imagery it actually
also will give you a lot into their psyche basically you'll get to see a lot about what they are
thinking inside and when you're talking about a kid who's two or three years old who may not have
good communication skills this may let you know a lot about what's going on in there so make believe
we love it in fact the world's health organization remember says a kid who isn't allowed to play
is a kid who's being tortured but is there a difference in gender and play and there is to
a point um what we're saying is that we do know that peers tend to like to play with the same sex
especially between 24 to 36 months now there are a couple of different hypothesis out there why this
occurs and that maybe when we get into kindergarten we're back into playing with other kids
but usually we really still see that boys tend to gather together girls tend to gather together
um one hypothesis is that we tend to play with our own sex because of basically the way we play
that the boys more like the rough and tumble and the competitive the girls like more cooperative
and pro-social orientation and that's because of the difference that we have psychologically at
this point we know that for boys the most important thing in boy structure is status
and you want to be the fastest you want to be the tallest you want to jump the furthest
you want to be number one so when boys are playing together it's all about the competition but we
call it friendly competition basically you know i can play with you hard out on the basketball
court but then go have a beer with you afterwards girls on the other hand are more about
creating their groups girls survive within groups they need their groups and one group
does not really intermix with another group so where boys are more individualistic and they'll
play with all different types of boys girls they tend to be a little bit more group oriented
which is kind of interesting because when we think about who would be more likely to accept
somebody the opposite sex within their group most people say well girls will be more likely to
accept a boy who wants to come in and play in the dollhouse and the answer is no actually not
boys will be much more likely to accept a girl who wants to come out and run
a race with them or play basketball with them as long as she's competitive and she doesn't mind
getting dirty and sweaty because it's all about showing that i'm number one girls on the other
hand are all about the group and when a boy comes in to play with their dollhouse or whatever group
activity they're doing a game or something like this that boy is interrupting their group and that's
not where he belongs and i'm defending my group in fact you can see this really strongly when you
start to get to high schools girls will stay within their groups we call them cliques it's not really
so much a click as much as a social pattern that probably has been well established from way back
when we lived on the Great Plains of Africa we need more than myself in order for my kid to grow up
if i'm living out on the Great Plains of Africa i have to have other sets of eyes looking out for
predators because we were eaten and if i'm somebody who's outside the group i'm not going to have
other females who are going to help me watch my kid and get my kid to adulthood so what i need to
learn to do is be cooperative with the other females within the group and then we'll work together
in order to get our kids basically to adulthood if a male comes to fight with us i'm probably not
gonna be able to take down that male myself but if there's two or three females and we're all
screaming at him and our kids are behind us we have a better chance of chasing him off so girls are
all about cooperation finding that group staying with that group defending that group and bringing
that group up as high in society as they can so within that group if we have a girl who wants to
run for student body president and another one who wants to be the head of the drama department
somebody else who wants to go out for cheerleading generally all the females within the group are
going to support each one of these girls even though they may be different whereas with boys
what you're going to find is that one boy wants to be the head of the government the other one
wants to be the head of this and the boys will start getting competitive about that they'll start
maybe downplaying how much being the head of the student body is they won't help make posters they
won't hang things up the girls meanwhile are helping everybody why because if one or two of those
girls actually get that position if we get a girl who's the number one cheerleader and we get a girl
who's the head of the student body that raises all the girls in that group up whereas with the boys
if my person this other person across me gets to be the student body president that's going to lower
my position or my status you might say among the boys so we do see that that play tends to be
different and that play helps girls create the unity within their group where boys are using
play also to help them define their social status and that stays with them for almost all of their
life same with the females the book goes on to talk a little bit about helping others and I bring this
in just slightly so that we have a better understanding of what these are as we move forward and get into
some of the older ages prosocial behavior is just basically a behavior in which it helps somebody
else it's more about looking for ways to help a society help another person that doesn't really
benefit yourself so helping somebody get a better job because they're going to get me a better job
isn't really prosocial behavior going out and helping somebody after the hurricanes and you're
helping them clear their yard that's prosocial behavior because it makes nothing for you so
altruism is basically this prosocial behavior that doesn't have any benefit to myself but
it drives these feelings and responsibility toward others so we already know by 18 months old that a
kid can recognize somebody who's in distress that's why when you start hearing one kid cry they all
begin to cry in part they understand this and they don't know why somebody else is upset i'm upset too
i'll be upset with you what we really want to be able to do is begin to help children
understand prosocial behaviors and empathy now remember that kids until they're four years of age
really can't understand other people's thoughts and feelings so when we're talking about young
kids and we're talking about prosocial behavior there we want to do is play on the feelings that
they're having we want to model concern we want to go ahead and emphasize when they see something
if they see a sad cat then you know if there's something you can do for that cat i don't mean
have to take it home but you know if you can give it a little water and that makes it feel better
then the child is learning something there if the child sees something on tv and says you know i
want to give this you try your best you can to give the children those opportunities now as they
get a little bit older and they begin to understand other people's feelings so now we're talking
about the five-year-old what you can do is set up behavior patterns or activities in which you
can model both for yourself and for them activities that they can participate in now it's kind of
important that they get to sort of choose the activity to a point meaning is is you know are they
concerned about people not being hungry are they concerned about people not having clothing are
they concerned about kids who are in the hospital it needs to be something they connect to themselves
because we are talking about that time frame that we just talked about with Eric said where they
need to be able to be industrious where they can choose sort of their own things and so if you tell
them automatically that no we're not going to do that charity because that's not important enough
then again that sort of downplays my ability to make some choices and decisions that might be
helpful you know they may see make a wish and they want to do something like that so who says that
you can't help them gather little money up sell a few little games and donate that money to make
a wish have them do all the processing of that or maybe they can help you with whatever activity
that you do so for my household we've been giving to st. Jude since i think st. Jude's existed i don't
remember time when we haven't been writing a check every month to st. Jude's and sending it in and
as a little kid i actually helped write those checks i wrote the little amount in now we've
increased our amounts over the years but i can distinctly remember doing this and i'm still helping
my mother write checks to st. Jude every month so it was a behavior pattern that sort of stuck
with me and i look at this and i think maybe my childhood learned this so very early on my child
started helping write the checks to st. Jude so it just kind of helped us make sure that we are
showing that we're empathetic and if we model that behavior hopefully the children will pick that up
and be able to take some of that into their adulthood so the last topic we're going to tackle
in this lecture is gender and gender is something that's a very complex issue
first of all our society is not gender neutral we have social roles that guide us on how we should
behave how we should look and what is appropriate inappropriate behavior while the next generation
may be coming up and being a little bit more unisexed right now gender is still very important
to us as a society even little babies are basically labeled with colors or hair bands
how often have you met a parent and when you look down to the baby if you say
oh what a wonderful little girl and it's a boy they defend very good oh that's a boy it's a boy
or if you vice versa she's a girl and to really make sure you know that this baby who's just a
little blob is a girl they put this headband with a big flower on it to really identify this as a
girl we are very interested in making sure people identify our children correctly and why do we do
that because we feel that if they're identified wrong then they may not be given the appropriate
behaviors that we expect for this now there are lots of different theories out there on
gender kohlberg is one of the ones that's kind of interesting um it's a little bit interesting
because his was originally created a while back ago we're going to talk about kohlberg a little
later on when we talk about moral development but there isn't a total disrespect for his anymore
there may be some changing in it but it still seems to hold up even with the more modern way
that we look at things so the first thing is he said the first stage is what he calls gender
labeling and basically by the age of three um a child can say whether they are a girl or a boy
as well as the gender of other people however they don't really understand if this is a characteristics
that can change over time like the late the somebody's hair or the clothes that you're wearing
so what's interesting is the only way that they know that they're a boy or a girl is because
someone told them that they were a boy or a girl um it's not that uncommon in daycare centers when
you hear a little two and throughout three-year-olds start to talk and you hear a boy start to talk
about his penis um he may call it a willy or something else and this girl is going what the
heck is that i don't know what you're talking about and the boy will pull his pants on he says you
know a penis and the girl will pull her pants on and go i don't have one it's missing and that's
because we don't see each other naked um it's not like in the days we lived on the great plains of
africa where everybody was running around without clothes and so we could see the difference between
a boy and girl with their anatomies uh today we hide those parts of us uh for very specific reasons
i'm not advocating running around naked but it does make a little bit harder for a girl and a boy
to really understand what the difference is unless they're told so they get to preschool you know
somewhere around three or four that this will start and what they begin to realize is is that
gender is stable that children realize that boys will grow up to be dads and girls will grow up to
be moms however what's interesting is that they still understand that their gender can't change
in appearance or unless they choose to so what happens is is that they tend to have now
understood what boy and girl is by standards we set out there so girls wear pink and boys wear
blue girls have long hair boys have short hair um and when they begin to understand these standards
that's how they were able to label and understand if somebody else was a different gender so now
all of a sudden you've got this girl who suddenly won't wear anything but dresses because to her
a girl wears dresses and a boy wears shorts and pants and if she starts wearing shorts and pants
well I don't want to be a daddy I want to be a mommy now they understand that a boy will become
a man but remember they don't know that their gender won't change and so it's the time when you
might see little girls who won't cut their hair off or boys who won't wear certain colors I always
remember my nephew once when I said I was going to buy him a shirt he said now you don't buy me
girl purple and I kind of looked at him and I said well I'd never buy you girl purple and what is
girl purple I was planning on buying a green shirt and as it turns out he saw lavender's girl
purple but that royal purple is boy purple to me it's just purple but he saw a difference in it
and he was afraid to get girl purple now when they get to be somewhere between four and seven and
it will depend on the kid we get gender consistency so by about six or seven children begin to understand
that their sex is permanent across all situations and overall time you know once they develop this
understanding they also begin to act as a member of their sex meaning is is that they understand who
they are and that that's what they're going to be now we're not talking about people who believe
that they have the wrong gender and that's a whole different conversation but what we're talking about
is for the majority of the population now in this way what kohlberg is actually arguing is that the
most important aspects of gender development is not so much as biological instincts or cultural
norms but rather it's a child's cognitive understanding of the social world around them
and i use this particular image right here from target now target luckily has taken this out but
you'll notice that there are two sets of building sets there's regular building sets and there's
girl building sets not that anybody can have a building set so if i was a young boy and i was
in gender stability i would not want something that was labeled a girl building set because i might
think that i'd become a girl then even though i might like to have the stable even though i might
like to have the horses because i would like to be a show jumper one day or i think about having a
farm you know what happens is that the girl wants to have that dinosaur set but yeah you know that's
a boy set and i don't want to be a boy so there's a lot of pressure on young children to perform
and to figure out what social roles are and then maintain those social roles so this is where they
look to adults to figure this out and a lot of imitation goes through this also we have to
understand that there's a social status within their own groups so we don't find that people want
to be outside their groups at this young age you remember we're talking about little kids preschoolers
we're not talking about older kids at this point and so the little boy and the little girl want to be
able to go play with their little boys and their little girls and so they may look to what they
call their leaders on what it is to be this or what it is to be that and they want to imitate those
so that they can make sure that they are identified because remember with gender stability it's all
about what i appear like to understand my gender that i can make sure that i'm within the group that
that i believe that i should be in now some cultures are a lot more gender oriented than others so if
we look down in south america gender identity is much stronger down there than it is here in the
united states so in the united states we are we have no question about that both a man and a woman
can be a doctor but what the interesting thing is is how do little kids see it is they're still
stereotypes and not too long ago in australia they did kind of an interesting experiment they went
to a whole bunch of kindergartners first and second graders and they asked them to draw three
pictures the first picture was of a firefighter the second picture was of a doctor and the third
picture was of a jet pilot an air force sort of jet pilot now over 90 percent of the pictures were
all male so the kids only saw those three roles as basically male roles a very small percentage
and the small percentage who did draw somebody who wasn't male it was for the doctor they drew
female doctors there wasn't one female jet pilot drawn now after they drew the pictures they then
said would you like to meet these people would you like to meet a jet pilot would you like to meet a
doctor would you like to meet a firefighter and of course all three were women and that was very
confusing there was even one little boy you said you can't be a jet pilot girls can't fly jets
so we know my first grade my kindergarten that gender roles and gender identity is already out
there in in their sense of mind of what a typical person would look like who do who does that and
that's because it's all based back on those schemas now remember schemas and i know it seems like a
long time ago but those schemas that have been formed are really hard to get rid of because
remember it's my thumbnail it's my way to help me kind of get through the situation and if somebody
has asked me to draw a jet pilot i'm going to pull upon the scheme i have of what a jet pilot is
and so if it only reflects a guy being a jet pilot then as a little kid that's what i'm going to draw
now i covered this just a little bit um a second ago but gender schema theory says that how children
basically learn about gender is through what we see in learning those schemas with if they decide
it's an object activity or behavior is that are labeled as male or female and then they learn that
they should do those activities because they see themselves as male or female in fact once kids
begin to understand their gender they'll be more likely to play with gender specific toys watch
gender specific television shows and we really have to be careful about those gender specific
television shows what we are seeing is that sometimes we are not putting forth um the best
viewpoint you might want to say as far as the gender is concerned so having a young son myself
i will say that at one point i got really disappointed with the cartoons that are on there for boys
because it seemed like the smart boy was always sort of a geek and to be smart was not to be the
leader to be the most intelligent one actually you got made fun of um in there were some episodes
where the sort of popular boy was suddenly found to be smart and he didn't want to be seen as smart
because when he was smart he was put into a class full of kind of nerdy kids um you know that that
doesn't really give our young children the thought that to be smart is a good thing especially for
your male now we don't see that in the females tv shows in fact in the female tv shows the smart
one is the leader so what kind of things are we you know sort of telling our children when we look
at some of these activities especially when it's multiple shows not just one show but show after
show after show we can really begin to see where we might be influencing sort of their view points
now there is one more theory that's out there evolutionary theory and we shouldn't
ignore this one because we know that there's a different stream men and women there's a physical
difference between men and women our brains are not exactly the same different doesn't mean ones
better than the other just means different what's one of the interesting things is is that we probably
know that the reason that certain genetic makeup of women and certain genetic makeup of men were
successful or are with us because they were successful meaning is that as a man I had to be
able to throw a spear I had to be able to bring something down so an upper chest a strong upper
chest would be something that would help me bring home food and if I could bring home food
then there was a better chance that my children would eat and my DNA would get passed along
with women those women who were able to multitask and do multiple things at one time
be able to keep an eye on their kid be able to keep an eye on the guy be able to keep an eye on
spiders and find some places seep tonight and oh also find some berries to eat those women probably
were more successful and being able to raise children who got to adulthood thus their DNA moved
forward so there is this evolutionary theory that said that a lot of the traits and behaviors that we
have sort of encompassed as males and females come from this evolutionary plan that has developed
over time you know we know that there's a different body for different people depending on where they
grew up or evolved you might want to say within the world we know that people who evolved up in the
Himalayas they have more red blood cells than most people because of the light oxygen we know that
people who developed closer to the poles are lighter skinned everything by the way is lighter skin
look at the polar bears and the rabbits and all of that we know that people who developed their
bodies more toward the equator wind up being darker skin because they need the melanin to protect
themselves in the UV rays we even know that certain groups of people have more webbing in their fingers
if they tended to develop more toward the coast areas so we know that the body adjusted for the needs
that we needed to be a successful species so this argument is also that there was a developmental
issue within the brain and our traits and our behavior patterns so that we could continue to be
a successful species now there's a difference between saying that there's a genetic difference
between us and saying that one is superior and one is submissive you might want to say
we do know that all species need both males and females to survive and the truth is we don't need
a whole lot of males we need a lot of females but we don't need a whole lot of males so in one way
it's kind of interesting that when you're talking about babies and the ones that we tend to toss
around and think of them hardy we tend to think of the boys and yet bored babies are much more
fragile than girl babies they're much more likely to die girls are much more hearty than boy babies
and that's also why we may mature faster we're a heartier person you also need women to be able
to i hate to say a pop out babies early now in today's society we don't expect 10 year old or 12
year olds to be having babies but if we think about back on the great plans of africa yeah
we were having babies pretty fast we actually think that we may have been having babies
by the time that they were seven or eight we didn't have long lives don't forget we weren't
living to be 80 years old back then and so we were probably popping out babies a little bit earlier
than we do now our gestation period of being nine months is also a rather long time for a group of
people who are basically prey animals we become predators once we make tools but before that we
were we were eating we were eating a lot so you know this concept of gender and what part of our
gender comes from our genetics versus what part of our gender comes from our culture is something
that gender psychologists are always studying so that's it for chapter five and that also ends i
do believe the week for most of you i hope that you got something out of this if you have any
questions there's my email address and there's just not much left to see once you've seen a dog
in a lobster fighting see you soon